[Musica]
ciao a tutti sono paolo bearzot avete
mangiato bene
l'avete preso il caffè no vedo un po di
faccia addormentata in sala beh allora
mi sveglio io musica
[Musica]
ebbene dai video già tutti i più svegli
più attenti
adesso possiamo iniziare ma come mai di
fatto ascoltare questa canzone non solo
per svegliarli ovviamente dovete sapere
che non possa spiegare cos'è o come
fatto quali sono i segreti della musica
house suoi magari non conoscete neanche
quale è o come è fatta una canzone out
ha pagato a prendersi io avrei dovuto
portare una canzone molto famosa che
tutti conoscevate
ma per motivi di copyright non sono
riuscito quello che voglio dirvi è che
la musica house spenderanno nelle vite
di tutti quanti e non è solo le canzoni
che ascoltiamo noi giovani in discoteca
e poi c'è un altro motivo che come ad
ogni ted si inizia sempre con una
domanda che dovete ricordarvi fino alla
fine secondo voi fare una canzone al
proprio come questa o come quelle famose
che ascoltate alla radio è facile ma è
difficile da fare
c'è chi pensa che fare la canzone house
sia difficile perché ci vogliono anni e
anni di studio e mesi di lavoro per
farne una c'è invece chi pensa che fare
una canzone al sia facile e che non ci
voglia alcuna abilità speciale e oggi io
vi dico proprio questo che fare una
canzone house è facile è semplice
bisogna essere mica dei geni della
musica per fare una canzone perché un po
ce la tiriamo ci crediamo chissà chi
indossiamo i cappellini swag merda non
ci vuole niente se non un software è
giusto un pizzico di fantasia perché se
ce l'ha fatta fabio rovatti ce la fate
tutti voi ma questo spitz non sarà solo
una lunga lezione teorica
adesso possiamo passare alla pratica e
passiamo al punto 1 di come fare una
canzone
serve un software ma quando lo apriamo è
uno spartito vuoto non c'è niente dentro
adesso non posso mettermi qua e poi una
canzone da zero come giovanni mucciaccia
che tira fuori il progetto già fatto e
questa è la mia canzone
semmai rubate mi date almeno il 10 per
cento ovviamente se vi sembra un po
caotica è normale ma chi ancora pensa
che fare questa sia stato difficile
beh seguitemi innanzitutto come vedete
ci sono due colori riesce il dio per
distinguere le varie parti della canzone
il blu lodato alla batteria alla parte
ritmica le percussioni
in rosso la data la melodia alla
sinfonia ritornello
partiamo da quella più facile quella in
blu la batteria è subito voglio svelare
un segreto quello che i dj non vogliono
farvi sapere ogni singola canzone house
si basa su un ritmo semplicissimo che
suona così l'avete riconosciuto è il
classico brucia di ogni singola canzone
è fatto da soli due elementi il primo è
il calcio ha un suono duro potente alla
stessa suono di quando e potete provarlo
anche voi a casa
aspettate musica ad alto volume e voi
semplici nick alzano sul muro per fargli
smettere scientificamente provato il
secondo sono invece è il battito di mani
e si trova sempre sul secondo calcio non
sono più aperto più acuto calci e botte
di rimane insieme fanno ritmo facile ma
indispensabile per ogni canzone ausl ma
anche molto noioso dopo un po ci si
annoia sempre con lo stesso ritmo
allora ci vengono in aiuto le forchette
che non sono breve acuto e sano tra un
calcio e l'altro per dare più vivacità
più armonia la canzone ok da sole non
suonano propria bene ma quando sono
tutti insieme calci mani forchette che
stand è la vera energia della canzone
out
e con soli tre strumenti abbiamo fatto
il 50 per cento della canzone tutta la
parte blu era chiusa in soli tre
strumenti e come vedete non ci sono
chissà quanti i ritmi o tamburi
inimmaginabili la musica non sai bisogno
di questo a noi dj piaccia tenere le
cose facili
finita questa semplicissima dove non
sapeva neanche un pizzico di fantasia
passiamo alla melodia che è la parte più
bella perché qua ci basta solo mettere
il suono al posto giusto ma è adesso che
possiamo sfogare la nostra immaginazione
però non c'è veramente un metodo
migliore dell'altro perché la che la
sinfonia giusta
basta seguire immaginazione e visto che
io non ho chissà quale fantasia ho
scelto solo quattro note mi sol sido per
i più esperti e ha dato loro un ritmo
molto semplice
ma effettivamente è un po troppo banale
così allora ho aggiunto delle piccole
note di qua e di là parlando della
canzone un po migliore più colorato e la
melodia finale è questo
e che ci crediate o no questa è tutta la
melodia della canzone che si ripete
sempre uguale per l'inizio alla fine
magari non ci credete ma qua non ci sono
chissà quali arpeggi o note
difficilissime da fare nella macro che
fu il caos non c'è posto per questo e
noi dj non siamo neanche capaci
questa è tutta la melodia ma dobbiamo
trovare anche degli strumenti che la
portino il primo è il piano e l'abbiamo
già trovato però da solo non sono
abbastanza bene non è abbastanza forte
allora è un accompagnato da altri
strumenti come ad esempio una capo poi
il mio preferito è il basso poi un
organo
[Musica]
infine un elemento molto importante ma
che nessuno considera mai perché un
volume molto lieve e il sottopasso ma
una potenza incredibile infatti si
tenessero nelle parti più belle della
canzone
[Musica]
l'avete sentito l'ultimo pezzo è la voce
come c'è scritto qua ma non è la voce di
un cantante che parla di storia
strappalacrime di nuovo nella musica
house spesso non c'è bisogno di questo
questa voce è semplicemente un numero
registrato a cui dato più o meno le
stesse note della melodia e questo è il
risultato finale però come per il piano
ogni strumento ho preso da solo non sono
abbastanza bene non è abbastanza forte
ma quando sono tutti insieme come una
grande orchestra che spendono la vera
energia della canzone e questo è quello
che viene fuori
quindi abbiamo fatto la melodia con
poche note e giusto qualche strumento e
verrà accompagnata anche dalla batteria
di prima fatta da soli calci mani e
forchette
ma come si mettono insieme queste due
parti non possiamo farle suonare tutte
allo stesso tempo se no ci si annoia
dopo un po ovviamente qua la semplicità
della musica house ci viene in aiuto le
canzoni house c'è sempre uno schema
fisso delle parti già prestabilite che
si dicono a noi dj con poca fantasia
quale strumento mettere e quando
metterlo ad esempio una canzone house
inizia sempre con l'introduzione fatta
dalla batteria
[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'avevate mai vista così questo è già un
nuovo orizzonte sulla musica e adesso
inizia la vera canzone siamo
nell'intervallo dove esce di scena la
batteria ed entra la melodia con il
piano l'arpa e il basso il sottopasso
alla voce arrivano dopo quando la
canzone è più movimentata
[Musica]
ma adesso anche per la vera magia della
canzone non quello che tutti stavate
aspettando
siamo nel big dap la costruzione perché
costruisce lui una potenza incredibile
una voglia di sentire quello che c'è
dopo è dato da tre effetti tutti gli
elementi della melodia sono una su una
nota di questa nota sempre più vero se
sempre più verso l'alto poi se gigi un
tamburo chiamato mani veloci a un colpo
sempre più forte sempre più acuto infine
entra anche il vento e il vento non sono
sempre più forte come un aereo che sta
per decollare
questi tre elementi insieme creare un
inerzia grandissima che si fanno quasi
come sollevare e l'effetto dico che sto
parlando è questo
[Musica]
mi dispiace aver entrato sul più bello
devo prima spiegare quello che sta per
arrivare
siamo nel drop la caduta e questo è il
punto più bello di ogni canzone house
dove tutti battono le mani in discoteca
si scatenano ballano qua sono tutti gli
strumenti che abbiamo visto calci mani
forchette tutti quelli della melodia e
anche il vento che questa volta
discendente sprigiona l'energia che
abbiamo liberato e visto che ci sono
tutti fateci caso
cercate di ascoltarli e di capire come
sono messi uno insieme all'altra
il faccia ascoltare il drop ma anche un
pezzo di build up così sono meglio
[Musica]
durante tutto il mio speech ho
continuato a dirvi che fare questa è
facile che fare l'altro è semplice la
vita notato ma allora se tutto così
dannatamente banale voi avesse potuto
pensare a paolo come mai non sei un dj
di successo come mai io al 3 milioni di
persone
noi siamo diventati ricchi famosi con
queste musica house così facili da fare
beh avete ragione e non vi ho mentito
avete visto anche voi per fare una
canzone house è facile ma è qua c'è un
grande ma quello che vi ha spiegato oggi
è solo la punta dell'iceberg di una
canzone house completa fatta da dj
esperti questa canzone ma anche in molte
delle sue parti quando ascoltate una
canzone alla radio il discoteca e
pensate
ma questo è facile ce la faccio anch'io
a farla no no perché le canzoni quelle
fatte bene quelli che fanno alla radio
hanno dietro di loro anni anni di studi
e mesi mesi di lavoro per rendere
perfette in ogni parte anche se vi
sembrano fatte con superficialità mi
faccio un esempio un giorno un manager
di azienda chiama un artista per farsi
fare un luogo per la società
l'artista proprio davanti a lui prese
carta e penna e in pochi secondi
fece un bellissimo disegno con poche
linea il manager era contentissimo e
sperava che avrebbe potuto pagare lo sa
poco
l'artista però gli chiese un milione di
euro
il manager non sapeva cosa dire ha
stupefatto
ma l'artista di rispose un euro e per la
casa dalla penna gli altri 999 mila sono
per gli anni gli anni di studi che mi
hanno portato a fare in poco tempo un
disegno così bello e così semplice
quindi la prossima volta che si è tirata
una canzone housing disco tackle radio
pensate a questo pensate alla domanda
che vi ho fatto all'inizio una canzone
off è facile o difficile
beh avete ragione entrambi
fare una canzone off come l'ho fatta io
è facile ma fare una canzone haus fatta
bene
beh è tutta un'altra storia
[Applauso]